I have always really loved Marvel movies
Madam Webb was very enticing to me hi
Cassie web this movie is before she ends
up in a wheelchair she's hyper
intelligent and her greatest superpower
is her mind I knew he was going to
die I saw
it when Cassie begins to experience her
Clairvoyance she thinks she's losing her
mind you are the only one who can change
the future Madam Webb is unlike any
other superhero when you're thinking
about how Spider-Man flies through the
air or Venom when he changes it's so
mythical to us but with her it's all
psychological I can see the future and I
found that incredibly excited to
explore let's try that OT these Visions
are quite fragmented because she doesn't
see anything clearly I've seen that man
before so who is he Ezekiel Sims he was
in the Amazon with my mom right before
she died Madame web brings these four
superheroes words together you don't
think this is weird how we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all day the
Genesis and the Inception of what will
become you're showing off maybe a
[Music]
little